hi I'm Kat and these are the shocking
questions
hi I'm to have random necklaces queer I
and these are my shocking answers ready
I'm ready
are you ready okay who is your weirdest
celebrity crush James Corden oh yes did
you just say you like the chubster yeah
who is the worst dress celebrity the
trumpet the trumpet Donald yeah
agree who is the most overrated sip tea
in the entire there's like five okay so
I'm gonna list three first one is who is
the person you're most proud to have as
a follower on social media Gigi Hadid
that is major
I've got like Gemma Collins I love Gemma
Collins never bad but she's wonderful
major yeah who is the most famous person
in your phone contacts Emma Stone oh yes
if you weren't married which celebrity
would you most want to go on a date with
easy Shawn Mendes I would marry him in a
happiness bike harpy yeah I don't care
that I'm old enough to be his dad Harvey
if you had to punch a famous president
who would you punch I do have an answer
we have an answer Oh have you ever sent
or received a nude photo never never
never
good on you I've sent loads no here's
the thing let me tell you why I came up
in a time that the wear apps weren't a
thing and smartphones weren't really in
there and I was already married by that
time so written about but thank God but
have you ever been starstruck oh my gosh
every day
yeah every day we have the luxury of
going to amazing events and amazing
award shows and every time I'm there I'm
completely embarrassing though every
time I see somebody let's say Penelope
Cruz what passes by no idea what her
name was but really I was thinking like
it yeah I think my tits are great
really yeah man I worked really hard on
them right Oh No what is the most
disgusting habit Oh easy it's constantly
I got my time now you cannot buy your
tunic Terry as nobody wants your
toenails Rach you're self out of ten you
know we are confident queens on queer
eye so we are all tense there's nothing
to be ashamed of we are all tense
ooh what is the biggest age gap you
would date higher and lower lower Shawn
Mendes 20 and how do you 35 so Shawn
Mendes lower higher 50
50 I actually prefer an older man Shawn
Mendes is the only younger person have
fancy didn't ya ever I don't go for
younger men yeah I love an older man
my husband's an older man it's in eight
years what was the last thing you
googled on your phone um okay would you
date someone shorter than me oh yeah
absolutely yeah yeah no issue is your
husband - oh sure he's an inch taller
but if it's bit if there what's the
worst gift you've ever received from
your husband okay play snog marry avoid
with the Fab five but I will tell you is
we played this game and almost broke us
really because I refuse to sleep with
Jonathan Mendes there is a video an
observer angry about it but there is a
video simply of Jonathan saying why
don't you [ __ ] have you ever stolen
something if so what oh yes I stole
bonbons when I was like eight yeah the
the jar was open at the local
convenience store next to my school took
some and then I never met that computer
so thinking he might find me one day I
don't know still owned you yeah I feel
really bad about it we're just trying to
make a living
probably ruin his business yeah I
single-handedly took him down I know Oh
God what is the longest you've gone
without changing your underwear actually
this isn't it I'm not gonna shock you
because I change it every day I am a
very clean person this is normal right
have you peed in the shower in the last
year definite in like the last 35 years
no who does you I'm temperance cats my
biggest fan and this was shocking
answers very well good that was just on
the cover yeah do it on the cover babe
give me some advice stop peeking the
shower
you